this highway was one of the only things
that didn't flood here in northeastern
bangladesh
heavy rains combined with overflowing
rivers inundated this town
all my furniture is ruined the entire
house is under throat level water
a major embankment on the buttock river
has also breached affecting at least 100
villages
i've seen a huge flood in 2004 but this
time it's even bigger more serious
an estimated two million people are
displaced with their homes damaged or
destroyed
in this farming community men and women
are trying to save the harvest they have
left
drying their crops along highways
pasta is
i only managed to harvest one third of
my paddy from underneath the water
the rest was washed away it's been two
weeks since there was any sun excessive
rain has devastated whatever i managed
to collect i can't dry this off it's
rotting i'm appalled
many parts of bangladesh are prone to
flooding with about a fifth of the
country submerged every year
but climate scientists say our warming
world is making it more unpredictable
the monsoon season hasn't even started
yet
leah harding al jazeera